Here's a summary of the various three.js settings for magnification,
minification, and anisotropy. The minimal settings are listed first. The higher
quality ones, further down. Quality does cost more GPU processing time, so you
have to decide what settings you can justify. The norm nowadays is to have
linear magnification and the best quality mipmap filtering on. I should note
that anisotropic sampling does not exist on older GPUs. Though it's an
extension in Web GL. Each vendor has its own secret sauce as to how they
implement this algorithm. So rendering quality can vary. The maximum
anisotropic sampling rate can also vary from GPU to GPU. Calling the
getMaxAnisotropy function gives the maximum rate possible on the GPU running
the program. This is usually a power of 2 and usually no higher than 16. You
can set the value higher if you want. Three.js will use the highest level
available on the card. More samples cost more processing power so, again, you
need to decide what rate is reasonable. There are yet still better sampling
methods possible, anisotropic filtering is not the ultimate answer. I went into
perhaps excessive detail on this aspect of the GPU, but for a good reason. This
whole process of sampling and filtering comes up again and again throughout all
of computer graphics. If you take too many samples you're wasting time and
possibly causing other problems. Too few and you can get artifacts. Where the
samples are taken and how the samples are combined or filtered, can also make a
huge difference. Many processes can be though of in these terms. Did I
tessellate the surface enough to capture its essence? Should my computation
happen in the vertex shader or the fragment shader? Should my shadow buffer
have a higher resolution, or should I use a different algorithm? When I think
of computer graphics and rendering as a whole, I think of it primarily in terms
of sampling and filtering. Give the demo a try. It will show you the valid
levels for your GPU. If you only see a value 1, it means your GPU does not
support anisotropic filtering.